comme chaque mois nous recevons sur ce
plateau mais dany poké notre
chroniqueuse qui nous présente à chaque
fois des rendez vous pour les juniors
alors aujourd'hui ce soir en mélange
l'art et le sport avec la natation
synchronisée et oui c'est un sport peu
connu dont on parle en général qu'au
moment des jeux olympiques mais à vélizy
villacoublay un câble enseigne cette
discipline il accueille les enfants dès
l'âge de 3 ans les entraînements ont
lieu tous les samedis midi une heure de
kourou bien sûr la première leçon c'est
d'apprendre à nager
puis les entraînements s'allonge ça
passe à trois heures avec le mercredi et
les plus grandes travail qu'elle après
quasiment chaque jour de la semaine
écoutez aurélie l'une des entraîneurs du
club
à nous avons
avec le régime en tout cas ce qu'elle
dit dans l'interview c'est que c'est un
sport qui demande beaucoup d'engagement
de rigueur aurélie parle voilà de
travail musculaire d'assouplissement ce
qu'elles ont un travail à sec elles sont
pas tout de suite dans l'eau bien sûr
mais pas de panique la compétition peut
se faire dès 6 ans les peu les plus
jeunes vous faire des petits exercices
les nageuses ne font pas tout de suite
les figures parfois spectaculaires des
plus grandes comme on peut le voir
souvent dans les compétitions mais il ya
tout de même à la fin d'année le gala
c'est surtout une initiation à la
natation synchronisée
c'est un sport pour les jeunes filles en
tout cas qui est très complet parce
qu'on leur demande à la fois d'être
gracieuse on leur demande à voir la
force on lors il ya une écoute musicale
il ya aussi le fait d'être en équipe
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
intéressant
alors vous l'aurez peut-être remarqué
j'ai beaucoup utilisé le mot elle mais
il faut savoir que la natation
synchronisée est bien sûr ouvert ouverte
aux garçons
le club de vélizy vous attend donc pour
les garçons et pour les filles merci
beaucoup mélanie on vous retrouvera le
mois prochain pour une nouvelle
chronique consacrée au sport pour les
petits